you can okay don't sound like you kept
Asian girl another asian girl died after
paying price gouge for not you yet no I
think it's completely unfair to be
honest we are calling Nike thanks for
calling Nike but I can be modernist but
if you're male does this call may be
recorded for quality and training
purposes for the status of an existing
order press one for a new order two
returns and exchanges three gift card or
product voucher balance for or to speak
with someone press zero to help us serve
you better press star two return to the
main menu and select one of the options
press 0 to continue to an agent
connecting you to a customer service
representative just a moment hello and
thank you for calling Nike calm my name
is how can I help you yes that's correct
hi this is Kevin jib calling I'm calling
with a complaint and a question for you
mmm okay okay so from what I understand
no mic has closed all all the stores
right now as of right now right that's
correct and what is the reason for that
well basically we're working on the
well-being of your teammates and
customers as well they're our top
priority so there was a decision made to
close or close out the stores in
multiple countries
you know seeing as the virus and
everything that's going on this closure
will be effective March 16th through
Friday March 27th
okay and the stores are expected to
reopen okay so basically from what I'm
understanding that's for the best
interest of your employees and customer
that's correct
but I want to know why
compassion for your Asian because your
store is not closed in Asia and off you
closed all stores for for Colvin 19 best
that's the virus about you talking about
mm-hmm that's correct
I know you didn't say well flu do you
say well foo I know I said the virus the
corona virus the virus virus from where
the corona virus where the front row
major oh now we get to the root cause
it's from Asia that's right that's right
from Asia okay but you not you're not
closing down your stores in Asia you
don't care about your asian asian
employees Asian consumers do not count
it do we not count as people no no
nobody's saying that right now I'm
American Asian okay I proud American
Asian I have to cuz it free cousin
forceful move and then I have another
cousin and uncle in Asia they tell me I
say Oh Auto Nike store clothes all night
they say no no not all night I see right
now that what I'm walking into a nice
door right now by mr. Apple mm-hmm okay
yes sir what I can do in this case is
notate your concern and I can send it to
corporate of course again I do
understand your frustration I really
couldn't tell you why people could die
why you deal with your your bloated
bureaucracy put it through suggesting
box tell people hey this guy not you're
not happy maybe after that I only have
maybe I only have five cousin and no
uncle you understand time is up right
now understood why would you not close
down the store in Asia and it's all is
it all of it do you know is it all of
Asia or just or just ten hour
well I'll be honest I'm not sure Oh
the official memorandum says that you
know some countries like South Korea
Japan Japan most of China are currently
open
but again well I just took a ride
through Chinatown and guess what they
open in Chinatown so I'm telling you
it's not just Asia it's not just because
of it's just not continental Pan Pacific
policy this is an extermination this
genocide that's a genocide it's not just
Asia it's not Geographic it's not
topographic Sybase a mountainous region
not like not not the caucus mountain is
anywhere there's Asian people even in
Chinatown is it Francisco filter it's
open right now you never send you a
picture from a Hawaii I don't sir I
believe you
I've my family pee-wee from China and
then we have an ancestor from even
farther east go on a map right find a
photo spot in Asia go for it okay so
that whole swath of people they are
exposed to this virus fatality rate like
we've never seen and then in Chinatown
in San Francisco so I'm trying to ask
you where are you from your ancestors
because that matter our people yes sir I
do understand you Spanish imagine that
if let's say Reebok Reebok says okay
we're gonna cruise or a store okay
except mm-hmm so Mexico in El Paso
mm-hmm you know Mexican tacos thing
right in on abort abort hot sauce
restaurant you start to say haha there's
a part I feel pattern here it's not just
one place geographically it's always
with Mexican people yes sir
make sense so how can we do we need it
fixes now we need to be working exactly
on that again
I'm not eating everything so that they
can you know start working on their app
the thing is that I really can't tell
you anything I was in Chinatown okay I
was looking for it for four nights
sneaker and because it open in Chinatown
because nice say okay don't matter I'm
just trying to people that's fine we'll
call that just calling calling the
masses open in Chinatown now here to say
I do need Nike
I do need night shoe for my daughter
okay I go in I look for for night mx2 70
react you know less you right very nice
you do you know how much the shoe cost
for Nike Air Max 270 we yet the 270 yes
believe those goes for what like 150 ah
you sure like your makes you 70 react I
would say like you know it depends on
the style but no demands shoe okay I
want you to look this up make sure I'm
not a liar you call me a liar I'm not
okay I just want me to not call me a lot
men's shoe Nike Air Max 270 we act 136
97 mm-hmm I just hit here the woman okay
now for go full girl how much 150 feet
97 that's twelve point four percent
higher for girl shoe same shoe same shoe
not every shoe I'm not talking about
Nike Dunk Nike
90 pairs
I'm talking about Nike Air Max 270 react
men go in by shoot Chinatown pay 136 97
same shoe and Max 270 react girl go and
buy for Chinatown or me for my my
daughter 153 97 why are you putting a
pink tag right I'll make you react does
seem fair to you no no that's not fair
it's not fair that you open in all of
Asia in Chinatown and you charging a
pink tax for women what about Nike
mmm-hmm is this a policy of Nike we say
a policy say hey we inclusive right I
see Nike support it support gay pride
all that all the people all the
decadence to the west on it but then but
come to progress we don't care about
Asia right oh go most of all Asian girls
you go Nike sadder to whites this man
you'll go and take your daughter dry on
a bathtub for Nike care you can't don't
sound like you care now the asian girl
another asian girl died after paying
price gouge for Nike we yet I don't know
believe me sir I do care and I'm hearing
everything again I'm notating everything
that's pretty much what I can do what's
your opinion on this before then I want
to have to talk to supervisor but what
is say no I think it's completely unfair
to be honest I'm hearing this from you
now you know I have a better
understanding now to be honest we
basically have that official statement
the rest heard to us and that's
basically what we have but you know if
you ask me personally I do think it's
like you were saying unfair okay
sure why that's official position of
night I can take that official statement
Nike say because famous statement it's
unfair I just want to make sure I know
use people night
well I don't I mean you did say you
speak for Nike I asked opinion you say I
FIFA night it's not fair
Nike not care about engine I'll go I
never said that I mean I have my
personal opinion I'm you can personally
I can say you want me to rely on the
tape but you recorded for quality
purposes so what's my chick I record I
have a call for quality insurance
purposes
you say that's okay I'll write down
right now at night say not fair
Nike nah care about Asian consumer logo
no sir
thank you a CL you have a nice a hey
there YouTube you are subscribed to the
channel hit the notification bell if
you're already subscribed to this
channel because that lets you know when
new videos come out and they don't show
up on the youtube search feed also there
are videos playing in boxes here click
one of those just of all the things that
I just mentioned all you have to do is
one and if you don't I will run for the
United States presidency under the one
1000 64% Cherokee party I have yet to
pick my VP